-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
Hope you're doing well tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
we are gonna get to the news.
During his speech last night
at a rally
for gubernatorial candidate
Terry McAuliffe,
President Biden attacked
former President Trump
and said he was "the only
president since Herbert Hoover
in the '30s to see more jobs
lost than gained."
Which is why Biden voted
against Trump
AND Hoover.
[ Laughter ]
During the same speech,
President Biden criticized
Republican candidate
Glenn Youngkin and said
that extremism "can come in
a smile and a fleece vest,"
whereas obstructionism
prefers denim.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Arizona Senator
Kyrsten Sinema
is receiving attention
on social media
after she wore a denim vest
presiding over the Senate.
Well, she was either
presiding over the Senate
or the Breakfast Club.
[ Laughter ]
West Virginia Senator
Joe Manchin complained
during a speech yesterday about
his fellow Senate Democrats
and said, "I have a hard time
and I'm totally out of sync
with 48 other Democrats."
Well, then, just a thought,
but maybe it's you.
[ Laughter ]
That's like your friend saying
his last 48 girlfriends
have been psychos.
Like, at that point, it's just,
like, suspicious odds.
According to reports,
a cyclist in Alaska
managed to fight off an attack
from a 500-pound brown bear.
But that was the easy part.
The hard part was getting
the bear onto the scale.
[ Laughter ]
No, see, this is the worst thing
you can do.
Because Ian...
So, our writer Ian,
he just sits at home, and what
happens is we send out setups,
which is, you know,
the first half of the joke.
Ian doesn't do any work.
He doesn't read the news.
He doesn't...
[ Laughter ]
All he gets are the setups and
he sees, "Oh, 500-pound bear.
I wonder how they...
you know, a scale?"
[ Laughter ]
So that's -- you know,
he just -- it's just so --
it's just ba-- it's just --
it's worthless.
[ Laughter ]
But it filled time.
It filled time.
[ Laughter ]
I actually really like
that joke.
I feel bad now.
Japan's Princess Mako
got married yesterday
to a so-called commoner,
which marks the end
of her royal status.
This news first reported by
a very drunk maid of honor.
[Slurring] "I mean,
what were you thinking?"
[ Laughter ]
"I was there -- Hold on.
I was there when she met him
and I was like,
[quietly] he's a commoner!"
[ Laughter ]
A zoo in Colorado announced
this week that 11 lions
and two tigers have tested
positive for the coronavirus.
So far they only have
mild symptoms,
which is more than can be said
for the guy
who had to swab them.
[ Laughter ]
[ Scattered applause ]
I like that eight people
were like,
[stammering] "Oh, no!
Oh, no, I'm --
I'm clapping for the victim
of a lioncide."
I guess lioncide would maybe be
if you killed a lion.
Look it up.
Don't just stare at me,
Shoemaker.
[ Laughs ]
And finally,
according to a new survey,
less than 20% of Americans
said that they eat
the wider, yellow end
of candy corn first,
whereas the other 80% actually
turn the candy corn around
and then chuck it in the trash.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody.